운동화나 스포츠웨어를 떠올리면 가장 먼저 어떤 브랜드가 생각나시나요?
아마 대부분은 나이키, 아디다스, 푸마 같은 브랜드를 떠올릴 겁니다.
조금 더 아웃도어 쪽으로 가면 아크테릭스, 살로몬, 제굴프스킨 같은 브랜드도 생각나죠.
그런데 여기서 한 가지 흥미로운 변화가 생기고 있습니다.
이 브랜드들 가운데 일부가 이제 중국 스포츠웨어 기업과 깊게 연결되고 있다는 겁니다.
아크테릭스와 살로몬을 보유한 아메리스포츠의 최대 주주는 중국 안타스포츠입니다.
제굴프스킨도 안타스포츠가 인수했습니다.
그리고 최근에는 푸마 지분을 인수하기로 하면서 거래가 완료되면 푸마의 최대 주주가 될 예정입니다.
겉으로 보면 한 중국 기업의 성공 스토리처럼 보입니다.
하지만 조금 다르게 보면 우리가 알고 있던 글로벌 스포츠 브랜드의 소유 구조가 바뀌고 있다는 이야기이기도 합니다.
여기서 질문이 생깁니다.
안타스포츠는 단순히 중국 안에서 잘 나가는 노컬 브랜드일까요?
아니면 나이키와 아디다스가?
아디다스가 지배해온 스포츠웨어 시장의 질서를 바꾸려는 새로운 축일까요?
그리고 더 중요한 질문은 이겁니다.
이 흐름을 그냥 기업 성장 스토리로만 봐야 될까요?
오늘은 안타스포츠의 성장 과정을 통해 중국 기업들이 어떻게 단순 제조업체에서 글로벌 브랜드 소유자로 이동하고 있는지
그리고 이 변화가 왜 스포츠웨어 시장 전체의 중요한 신호인지를 살펴보겠습니다.
먼저 현재 위치부터 한번 보겠습니다.
안타스포츠는 2025년 매출 802억 이완.
우리 돈으로.
대략 17조 원대 매출을 기록했습니다.
영업이익은 190억 이완 수준이었고 영업이익률은 23.8%였습니다.
수준만 보면 이미 큰 회사입니다.
하지만 더 중요한 건 중국 시장에서의 위치입니다.
안타스포츠는 중국 스포츠웨어 시장에서 나이키와 아디다스를 제치고 1위권에 올라섰습니다.
기간 추정치마다 차이는 있지만 2024년에는 약 23% 2025년에는 약 21.8% 수준의 점유율이 언급됩니다.
이 말은 중국 소비자들이 더 이상 스포츠웨어를 고를 때 무조건 나이키와 아디다스를 선택하지 않는다는 뜻입니다.
물론 글로벌 전체로 보면 아직 나이키와 아디다스의 규모가 훨씬 큽니다.
안타스포츠가 당장 이들을 넘어섰다고 말하기는 어렵습니다.
하지만 여기서 봐야 할 것은 현재 순위가 아니라 방향이죠.
나이키와 아디다스가 중국 시장에서 예전만큼 압도적인 위치를 유지하지 못하는 사이 안타스포츠는 중국 내수 시장에서의 위치를 유지하지 못합니다.
나이키와 아디다스는 중국 시장을 기반으로 성장했고 이제는 글로벌 브랜드를 사들이며 해외 시장으로 나가고 있다는 겁니다.
이건 단순히 중국 브랜드 하나가 잘 팔린다는 이야기가 아닙니다.
중국 기업이 생산만 하던 위치에서 벗어나서 브랜드를 소유하고 유통망을 장악하고 소비자와 직접 연결되는 단계로 이동하고 있다는 뜻입니다.
그럼 이 회사는 처음부터 강한 브랜드였을까요?
그렇지는 않습니다.
안타스포츠는 1991년 중국 푸젠성 진장에서 시작했습니다.
창업자 딩수중은 21세 회사를 세웠고 초기에는 글로벌 브랜드 제품을 대신 만들어주는 OEM 기반에서 출발했습니다.
쉽게 말하면 처음에는 자기 브랜드로 세계 시장을 움직이는 회사가 아니라 남의 브랜드 제품을 만들어주는 제조업체에 가까웠습니다.
이 지점이 중요합니다.
과거 중국 제조업은 싸게 빠르게 많이 만들어주는 역할에 강했습니다.
하지만 제조만 잘해서는 수익률에 한계가 있습니다.
진짜 가격 결정권은 브랜드를 가진 회사가 가져갑니다.
소비자와의 관계도 브랜드가 가져갑니다.
안타스포츠는 이 구조를 이해했고 어느 순간부터 단순 생산이 아니라 자체 브랜드를 키우는 쪽으로 방향을 바꿉니다.
초기 전환점은 스포츠 스타 마케팅이었습니다.
1999년 안타스포츠는 중국 탁구 스타 쿵링우이를 홍보대사로 발탁합니다.
그리고 2000년 시드니 올림픽 남자 탁구 결승에서 쿵링우이가 안타 유니폼을 입고 우승하면서
안타라는 이름이 중국 소비자들에게 빠르게 알려졌습니다.
이때 안타가 얻은 것은 단순한 광고 효과가 아니었습니다.
중국 스포츠 브랜드도 국가대표 선수와 연결될 수 있고 스포츠 시장의 중심에 설 수 있다는 인식을 만든 겁니다.
이후 안타스포츠는 중국 내수 시장을 빠르게 파고들었습니다.
중국에서는 중산층이 커지고 건강과 운동에 대한 관심도 높아졌습니다.
스포츠웨어도 더 이상 운동할 때만 입는 옷이 아니게 됐습니다.
출퇴근, 주말 외출, 여행, 러닝,
등산까지 일상 전반으로 들어왔습니다.
2024년 중국 스포츠웨어 시장은 약 4,089억 위안 규모로 추정되고
2029년에는 5,423억 위안까지 커질 것으로 전망됩니다.
안타는 이 흐름 속에서 중국 전역에 매장을 촘촘하게 깔았습니다.
2025년 기준 안타 브랜드 매장만 7,200개가 넘고 안타 키즈 매장도 2,600개 이상입니다.
여기서 안타스포츠의 강점이 보입니다.
이 회사는 단순히 운동화를 만든 회사가 아닙니다.
중국 시장 안에서 브랜드, 가격대, 제품군, 유통망을 동시에 운영하는 회사입니다.
동시에 이 지점은 경계해야 할 부분이기도 합니다.
중국 내수 시장에서 확보한 유통망과 현금 흐름을 바탕으로
안타스포츠는 이제 중국 밖의 브랜드를 사들이고 있습니다.
중국 안에서 쌓은 힘이 글로벌 브랜드 인수에 기반이 되고 있는 겁니다.
안타스포츠의 전략은 한 문장으로 정리할 수 있습니다.
스포츠라는 한 분야에 집중하되 하나의 브랜드에 의존하지 않고
여러 브랜드를 동시에 운영하며 세계 시장으로 확장하는 전략입니다.
그래서 안타는 이미 세계 소비자들이 알고 있는 브랜드를 확보하는 방식을 택했습니다.
대표적인 사례가 2019년 아메리스포츠 인수입니다.
그리고 2026년에는 푸마 지분 29.06%를 약 15억 유로에 인수하기로 했습니다.
여기서 중요한 질문이 나옵니다.
왜 하필 푸마였을까요?
푸마는 최근 실적만 보면 좋은 상황은 아니었습니다.
브랜드 경쟁력과 판매 품질을 다시 회복시키고
회복해야 하는 과제도 안고 있었습니다.
그런데도 안타가 푸마를 선택한 이유는 분명합니다.
푸마는 여전히 전 세계 소비자들이 아는 브랜드입니다.
유럽과 미국에서 오랜 역사가 있고 스포츠와 패션 양쪽에 걸쳐 있는 이름입니다.
안타가 처음부터 이런 글로벌 브랜드 인지도를 직접 만들려면 시간이 오래 걸립니다.
푸마 지분 확보는 그 시간을 줄이는 선택에 가깝습니다.
다만 이 거래를 무조건 성공으로 볼 수는 없습니다.
물론 안타가 푸마를 회복시키면 글로벌 대중 스포츠웨어 시장으로
더 빠르게 들어갈 수 있겠죠.
반대로 푸마 회복이 늦어지거나 소비자들이 중국 자본 아래의 푸마를 낯설게 받아들인다면
부담이 될 수도 있습니다.
그래서 중요한 질문은 이겁니다.
글로벌 브랜드가 중국 자본 아래에 들어간 뒤에도
기존의 브랜드 정책성과 소비자 신뢰를 유지할 수 있을까요?
안타 스포츠는 단순히 중국판 나이키라고 보기 어렵습니다.
나이키와 아디다스는 하나의 강력한 브랜드를 중심으로 성장했습니다.
하지만 안타는 다릅니다.
안타 휠라.
아크트릭스, 살로몬, 제골프스킨, 푸마처럼
여러 브랜드를 묶어 시장별로 나눠서 접근하고 있습니다.
이 전략은 강력하지만 운영은 훨씬 복잡합니다.
브랜드를 사는 것과 브랜드를 오래 키우는 것은 다른 문제입니다.
각 브랜드의 정체성을 지키면서 지역별 소비자 취향과 제품력까지 맞춰야 합니다.
현재까지 안타는 중국 시장에서는 성과를 냈습니다.
하지만 해외 시장에서는 아직 검증 단계입니다.
안타 스포츠는 아직 글로벌 1위가 아닙니다.
하지만 중국 시장에서는 강력한 위치에 올라섰고
글로벌 시장에서는 브랜드를 직접 키우는 방식과
기존 브랜드를 인수하는 방식을 동시에 쓰고 있습니다.
이 이야기는 중국 기업이 세계 시장에서
어떤 방식으로 영향력을 넓히고 있는지를 보여주는 사례입니다.
앞으로 스포츠웨어 시장을 볼 때 우리는 나이키와 아디다스만 보면 안됩니다.
안타 스포츠가 어떤 브랜드를 더 확보하려는지
중국 밖에서 소비자를 얼마나 설득할 수 있는지
그리고 푸마를 어떻게 할 수 있는지
어떻게 회복시키는지를 함께 봐야 합니다.
결국 핵심 질문은 이겁니다.
우리가 익숙하게 소비하던 글로벌 브랜드들이
한해둘 중국 자본으로 들어가는 흐름을
이거 그냥 시장의 자연스러운 변화로만 봐도 될까요?
안타 스포츠의 이야기는 운동화 회사 하나의 이야기가 아닙니다.
앞으로 글로벌 소비 브랜드의 주인이 누가 될 것인가에 대한 이야기이기도 합니다.
오늘도 영상 시청해 주셔서 감사합니다.